мусим виживати нема додіться Анна
Василівна живе у Бородянці її гуртожиток
російський військові обстріляли з танка
ще у березні під час тимчасової окупації
будинок в аварійному стані пошкоджені
дах стіни та комунікації це світло
зробили і це все так обігрівач
виключаємо щоб нагрітися хоч трохи Да і
все це газу немає
Води немає
ходим
по людях воду
у кімнаті стоїть старенький обігрівач
він її єдина Надія не замерзнути взимку
обігрівач гріє
нас ще двері такі що
одні щелі закривають одеялом щоб не було
ми як прийшли сюди
посеред хати двері так як навісили так і
сидимо та якщо відключать світло
пенсіонерка просто не зможе вижити в
морози
одягатися будемо вкутувати Та так і
будемо сидіти а що робити Росія
продовжує обстрілювати українські міста
Щоб залишити людей без газу та електрики
10 жовтня ракетами пошкодили 11 важливих
об'єктів критичної інфраструктури у
восьми регіонах України та в Києві Через
це у частині областей були перебої зі
струмом та водопостачанням загалом
унаслідок російської агресії уражено
понад пів тисячі котелень
теплоелектростанцій і теплових пунктів
є запаси вугілля на сьогодні так вони їх
поки що недостатньо там орієнтовно цифри
називали міненергетики близько 2
мільйонів тонн вугілля якщо вважати там
на весь опалювальний сезон чого не
вистачить нам тому що
в зв'язку з тим що ми
в нас захоплені Запорізька
Тез або захоплено або зруйновано те це в
Охтирці в Кременчуці
зруйновані тому у нас є деякі
намічається деякий дефіцит
електроенергії в опалювальний сезон І
тому ми сьогодні вже там спалюємо
вугілля ситуація з газом також складна
каже експерт але держава і місцева Влада
продовжує підготовку до опалювального
сезону у тому числі й на випадок
влучання ракет у Теплокомуненерго
закуповує генератори мобільні котельні
готує програму забезпечення дровами
територіальних громад готується й
українці перевіряють електрощитові у
будинках утеплюють вікна та купують
обігрівачі щоб нам хоть не було з
балкона то ми ось Ну так уже
позаклеювали собі воно наче не дує
обігрівач у нас є якщо буде світло і
буде все нормально напруга все то якби
мерзнуть ми не будемо зимою Але ж ми не
знаємо чи буде ще все добре світлом Ну
так як
не буде світла Тоді я не знаю як ми може
підемо ну часний будинок до сестри якщо
у багатоквартирному будинку не буде газу
і тепла догрітися можна
електрообігрівачем від літа попит на них
зріс у понад 50 разів літерами категорії
знову ж таки є теплові панелі конвектори
та масляні обігрівачі кожен з цих
приладів може обігріти стати основним
джерелом опалення як невеликої кімнати
до 5 квадратних метрів так і обігріти
велику площу площею до 35 квадратних
метрів масляні обігрівачі будуть довше
нагріватися але й довший віддавати тепло
а конвекторні та керамічні нагріють
швидко але так само швидко й охолонуть
тому обирати треба індивідуально так
само можна купити звичайну настільну
електроплиту щоб готувати їжу і гріти
воду але треба пам'ятати що усі ці
прилади можуть перевантажити
електромережу потужність яка в
середньому надається на одну квартиру
що на увазі старих будинках більшості
старих будинків це всього 2,5 кВт 2,5
кВт - це холодильник телевізор включена
освітлення в квартирі там І нехай це
буде комп'ютер і більше ви нічого не
зможете підключити кожен сусід ваш на
поверсі під'їзді повинен розуміти що
якщо всі одночасно включать
опалювальні прибори такі як масляні
радіатори витор дуйки все інше то
погорить у вас і проводка По гарячих
щитовій визовите пожежі це може провести
до літальних наслідків тому всі
електричні прилади потрібно розводити по
кімнатах і не вмикати одночасно в ідеалі
домовтеся із сусідами про графік
вмикання електроприладів вистачить
поділитися на парні і непарні квартири у
приватному будинку все простіше якщо
перебито газогін можна палити дровами і
купити генератора або піч буржуйку а от
у квартирі можна використовувати
портативні кемпінгові пічки і газові
пальники з балонами щоб зігрітися і
приготувати
у нагоді стануть свічки ліхтарі та
батарейки обов'язково треба мати
заряджений Power bank чи акумулятор і
запастися теплим одягом і термобілизною
та якщо у багатоквартирному будинку
взимку не працюватиме електрика тепло і
каналізація тоді з нього треба буде
евакуюватися будинок нежити діяльність і
в цьому випадку люди не зможуть нову
знаходитись тому що не будуть працювати
насоси не буде працювати вся система і
фактично потрібно зливати воду з системи
теплопостачання і переїжджати це
найперше радять зробити жителям
зруйнованих деокупованих міст в яких Не
встигнуть відремонтувати Всі комунікації
до зими